I have come together again with one
woman charity who I trust Hamden Allah
who had 100 donation policy we are now
raising funds to build houses for those
who have been homeless due to natural
disasters in Afghanistan Syria and
Pakistan please donate whatever you can
may Allah build you guys at home for
helping and enabling them to have a
house
[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are inshallah I'm here
with Dijon smile to Janna hello how you
doing fellow alhamdulillah good okay so
I was going to do a reaction video to
this um but I thought some interesting
points because the reason why Andrew
Tate came to Islam was a little
different to how sneaker came to Islam
yeah
um and in a nutshell
um yeah it's interesting to see you know
he was he used to talk about this I
think he even reacted to one of my
videos where he saw some stuff and he
was you know a little bit critical but
let's just find out what was the reason
he came to Islam and see what we can
make out of here
I said I was just pointing out why I
have always why I resonate with Islam
why it makes sense for me because I
don't like the idea that you worship a
man I believe that Jesus Christ was a
prophet I believe that Jesus Christ was
real but I don't think that you should
have him bloody as hell on a cross and
like you prayed it it's weird it doesn't
make sense to me to pray to a man I
don't want to submit to a man the only
person that we should submit to and that
we should pray to should be the one
creator of the universe which is Allah
you create the universe and we love him
for it perfect that really it makes the
most sense to me I don't want to say
like Jesus is also God and he's also a
man and there's a Holy Spirit and Christ
is God because he rose so he's a man it
doesn't what doesn't make sense Muhammad
what I like about Islam and why it's
it's harams they don't even if they're
not just supposed to draw Jesus Christ I
think a lot of Muslims find it
disrespectful that Christians are put
Jesus everywhere blood is hell all these
crosses because we shouldn't and that's
why I didn't realize it with
Christianity like growing up it's just
like all the images that they put of God
it doesn't make sense to me we can't we
are not capable of visualizing what the
creator of the universe looks like what
he's doing why is he in a cloud chilling
with a beard why is he white why is God
it doesn't make any sense so there's no
point in us even conceptualizing it
because we can never have the capability
to
and like the fact that you pray five
times a day Islam that's you're going to
be more grounded there they take prayer
more serious than any other religion and
I like the fact that they separate
masculinity femininity how important
that is it fixes a lot of L well a lot
of elements out right now
every people get upset
it's just it's just food for thought I
have no I don't I still have the Bible
right here I still have the Bible right
here still read the Bible but
yeah I did convert I did convert I mean
think about it's not really rocket
science I mean what he's saying is basic
I mean with his videos of little kids
getting confused of the Abduction of the
Trinity like that doesn't make sense
yeah he's that little girl that was like
it's like but I thought Jesus I'm trying
to say yeah so it's not rocket science
and the people that's giving him the L I
don't understand if we take our Grudge
our ego our arrogance our stubbornness
out of the picture and genuinely look at
this matter and I genuinely believe if
Islam didn't exist
and you just went to a Christian and
said listen this whole Doctrine thing or
the Trinity of the Father the Son Holy
Spirit dying flesh all that kind of
stuff here
it doesn't make sense genuinely they
will be like they actually flipping
doesn't make sense
so the point is in a nutshell that what
he and there's there's actually famous
Unitarian
um a long time ago hundreds of years ago
he actually said this to the
trinitarians he says how much longer are
the muhammadins gonna laugh at us for
this doctrine of the Trinity wow it's a
bloody joke and it's simple like he said
man God it doesn't add up why do I have
to do that and to claim that God within
his nature and this is the reason why
millions of people are living I don't
think in history in time like since Adam
we have seen maybe millions of people
abandoning A specific group of faith I
don't have ever seen it in the
Westborough millions of people who live
in Christianity and it's for this very
sub reason the thing is the the core
beliefs of the religion has to make
sense if it is sent to All of mankind
yes which Christians claim although we
deny that claim but the thing is as
Muslims we we make the same claim but we
back it up I mean you look at the core
principles the core doctrines of Islam
that it's very simple a four-year-old
can understand it a five-year-old a
six-year-old a 20 year old 40 year old a
60 year old a person from the Easter
person from the West regardless of where
you are it's very simple and if that is
the reason why you're going to go to
heaven or hell it has to make sense it
has to be easy for you to comprehend it
cannot be something that people say oh
no it's just this look it's let's take
this analogy oh that analogy doesn't
work oh maybe it's this or maybe it's
that oh it's you're just supposed to
believe in it what do you mean if that's
the fundamental thing that everybody
regardless of language regardless of
culture has to accept to go to heaven it
has to be something that is digestible
exactly I mean just I was just thinking
of a sandwich in my head just imagine
standing in front of God Almighty and
he's like imagine as a someone's a
Christian is like okay what did I
command you to believe
um told me to believe that you sent your
son and you became your son but you're
also the Holy Spirit but the son is not
the father the father is not the Holy
Spirit the holy spirit's not the father
but you all are one but you died for the
sin
now can you imagine and then it's just
like you might just stand in front of
God Almighty Allah okay what did I
command you that you are one there is
nothing like you we worship you alone
finished done Dustin hello it's done do
you get it yeah it's simple as that and
it's only just that we do that because
we believe the greatest form of
Injustice in this life is to associate
Partners to God and sneako has rejected
that and said no I am not an associate
Partners to God Almighty I believe he
deserves worship and he's hidden if he
would
did you see how complex he got when he
was trying to spend on his face
reactions and the father and the son do
you see how confused he was yeah but
look at the official expression to that
compared to when he goes yes but I just
believe now there is one God and that's
Allah
he's not the only one a lot of people
have said that a very similar sentiments
and it still hasn't been refuted
convincingly that's why people are
leaving the religion in droves exactly
and would just wrap up with this
um study Oxford University of Justin
Barrett which is that they found out
that kids have the uh the propensity to
believe in one higher power and this is
why when people come and say you Muslims
say that every child is born a Muslim
that's right and the study shows that
they are born with that inclination that
if all religions were taken up the
picture that child would grow up
believing in one crater they will not
grow up believing the Trinity or the
Father the Son of the Holy Spirit they
would grow up believing that one supreme
high power and that's exactly what sneak
was submitted to that's what Andrew
Taylor submitted to and thousands if not
millions of people are submitting to it
to Islam and the truth is there so if
you're watching this as a non-muslim the
decision is yours we say come to the
truth and embrace it and submit to the
width of God almighty till next time
from myself and zeeshan smart agenda
goodbye